how sweet
meghan markle and prince harry show some
rare pda
with this smooch on sunday at the santa
barbara polo club
[Music]
after harry's team los padres won the
match megan presented the trophy to her
hubby and his teammates
she gave each athlete a kiss on both
cheeks before kissing harry on the lips
this rare moment between the couple was
followed by megan laughing as she wiped
her lipstick off harry's face
now you know when the duchess of sussex
steps out her outfit is going to be a
topic of conversation
megan was dressed to impress at the
event wearing a long sleeve black and
white polka dot blouse she paired the
top with white bermuda shorts and a
black belt
she also sported all black accessories
including a hat sunglasses and pumps
this is not the first time megan stepped
out to support her man at a polo event
earlier this month she was by harry's
side as he and his team took home second
place in the folded hills pope challenge
but back to that kiss
although it is still rare we are slowly
starting to see more pda from the couple
in april at the opening ceremony for the
2022 invictus games the royal couple
gazed into each other's eyes on stage
and megan handed harry the mic before
they locked lips
that moment came a few days before
prince harry opened up on today about
how he's adjusting to his new life in
california where he and megan have been
living with their two children archie
and lillabet and you know the home
home for me now is is you know for the
time beings and it's in this
and it really and it feels that way as
well that's it yeah it's we've been
welcomed with open arms um and it's got
such a great community up in santa
barbara so so you feel like that's home
more for you
[Music]
you